ich bin Jakob 25 Sozialarbeiter und
setze mich vor allem für das Thema queer
im Islam ein und das auch als meine
Rolle die kurdische Queen in drag alles
okay
[Gelächter]
salam aleikum mein Name ist Tugay ich
bin 25 Jahre alt schwul muslimisch und
Islam Wissenschaftler hi ich bin Ossi
USA mein Pronomen auf Englisch sind auf
Deutsch benutze ich gar keinen Pronomen
ich bin
super aktiv gerade mit den women
Sternzeichen live wieder collective
spielerisch und aus der muslimischen
Welt Menschen wie sie sind sehr
gefährdet in Ländern wie dem Iran oder
Katar wo das Thema Homosexualität gerade
im Fokus ist Bedrohungen aber auch hier
vor allem von islamistischer Seite also
ich habe Morddrohungen bekommen
Beleidigungen es gab schon viele
Situationen um mich Leute erkannt haben
auf der Straße in Köln zum Beispiel wo
wir verfolgt worden sind auch dort
beleidigt bespuckt zum Teil angegriffen
worden sind diese Reaktion waren schon
wirklich sehr enorm die liberale eben
Rust Moschee in Berlin ist ein Safe
space ein geschützter Ort für
muslimische Männer und Frauen geht weder
sexuelle Orientierung und Identität
Queen und muslimisch auf Polizeischutz
sind sie hier in der Moschee leider
angewiesen die kriegen viele
Morddrohungen von Islamisten
normalerweise
Androhungen dass sie diesen Ort
verbrennen in die Luft sprengen wir
kriegen natürlich als muslimische
Menschen auch Hass von rechts aber
haben in viel geringerem Maße das ist
dann eher so traurig sich auch anhört
der typische straßenrassismus der den
man dann erlebt aber ja aktiv auf uns zu
gehen und hassen uns bedrohen das machen
leider Islamisten
tik tok ist Ossis Plattform Ossi
schauspielert führt Regie vor allem aber
ist Ossi Aktivistin seit fünf Jahren in
Deutschland kämpft Ossi gegen die gender
Apartheid im Iran gegen die Todesstrafe
zu der aktuellen der Islamischen
Republik auch zwei lesbische Frauen
verurteilt worden sind
da sind zwei Kuriere Menschen die sind
verhaftet und wir sagen verhaftet aber
wir sind Kinder die sind hostig bei
islamische Regierung und die sind im
Gefängnis und die waren auch ein
Todesstrafe einfach weil die Queen sind
und das einzige Sache für die ist dass
die Bade hatten sich engagiert bisschen
safe space war einander und von der
Community machen nachdem sie Frauen über
die Grenzen Sicherheit gebracht hatte
wurde sie verhaftet
sariamani voller Angst kurz vor ihrer
Festnahme
sie sind hinter mir her ich muss sofort
hier raus ich weiß nicht ob ich das
schaffe
mein Leben ist wirklich ein großer
Gefahr
der muslimische Theologe alliandur weiß
in früheren Zeiten kannte die islamische
Welt dieses Ausmaß an queerfeindlichkeit
und Homophobie jedenfalls nicht im
Gegenteil sein Buch liebe Sex und aller
dokumentiert einen ausgelassenen
Hedonismus große Offenheit gegenüber
allen Formen des erotischen Miteinanders
überliefert ein Gespräch zwischen einer
Sängerin und dem Kalifen einmal Mohn
gleichberechtigt die Begegnung der
beiden
nichts ist köstlicher als Sex zwischen
Frauen
daraufhin stellte der Kalif seinen
Weinbecher beiseite drehte sich zu ihr
und sagte oh nein
Sex mit Frauen als Mann ist für wahr
köstlicher als Sex zwischen Frauen
[Musik]
der urteilsfreie Umgang mit
gleichgeschlechtlicher Liebe fand sich
sowohl unter den herrschenden Kalifen
als auch im normalen Volk
als Mann die Schönheit der Männer zu
feiern viele arabische persische und
türkische Dichter übersetzten ihre
homo-erotischen Fantasien schon ab dem 9
jahrhundert wie selbstverständlich in
frivol pornografische Bilder und Verse
zum Beispiel Abonnement
nicht aus dieser Epoche der spricht ganz
explizit darüber und er war auch ein
hoflichter also der blickte sehr enge
Kontakte mit den Kalifen also es ist
nicht etwas wie gesagt was ein Rand
Erscheinung der Gesellschaft war eine
Person der Öffentlichkeit ne
das reiche lieber Tina Erbe der Muslimen
Mystik und Dichtung mit der Kolonialzeit
wird es von einem rigorosen Moralismus
und victorianischer Prüderie
überschrieben
die Kolonialherrschaft der kommunalismus
er hat einige Kategorien mit sich
gebracht zum Beispiel die Kategorie der
Homosexualität die die damaligen
Menschen nicht kannten Salafisten Muslim
Brüder und andere Ideologien die
Arbeiten mit Kategorien die eigentlich
eher seit dem 19 Jahrhundert zwanzigsten
Jahrhundert überhaupt existieren ne das
heißt der wahre Muslim ist derjenige der
nicht homosexuell ist der wahre Muslim
verabscheuen sowas der Wahrung muss
Leben nie homosexuell mittlerweile gibt
es in der islamischen Welt so gut wie
keinen sicheren Ort für Quere Menschen
im iranen Saudi-Arabien im Jemen müssen
sie sogar mit der Todesstrafe rechnen
Ossi hat sich dem Kampf für die
Menschenrechte verschrieben für das
Leben der zwei lesbischen Frauen im Iran
die zum Tode verurteilt worden die ihren
safe space verloren haben
hier in Berlin in der eben Rust Moschee
herrscht ein freier Geist ein Ort wo
islamische Spiritualität und Mystik
einen Platz haben für Jakob Anlaufstelle
und Schutzraum zugleich in meiner Bubble
damals hätte ich niemals geglaubt dass
es eine Moschee gibt
die tatsächlich uns als queere Menschen
akzeptiert und sogar für uns einsteht
das habe ich nie gesehen und es war für
mich unvorstellbar und als gemerkt habe
okay hier ist ein safe place wo ich
meine Religion ausüben kann ausleben
kann und dafür nicht sage ich mal
diskriminiert werde war das schon Gold
wert
einen sicheren Ort finden für sich und
andere bleibt eine überlebenswichtige
Aufgabe für queere Muslime überall in
der Welt